you say I'm gonna find a way I'm gonna
make the way what is it that's gonna
truly fulfill you things getting things
is not gonna make it happy you want
clients for life not just customers they
want you to supply them more information
he'd never thought through an exit
strategy he got almost nothing for it
there's a resource that people believe
is missing but failure comes from all
the little things activity without high
levels of purpose is the drain of your
fortune so use your body and your voice
he's an american motivational speaker
personal finance instructor and
self-help author he became well known
from his infomercials and self-help
books in 2013 Forbes estimated his net
worth to be four hundred and eighty
million dollars he's Tony Robbins and
here are his top ten rules for success
ultimately if you're gonna have lasting
change in anything you're really talking
about just raising your standards I mean
I always tell people if you want to know
how to change your life and give it to
you in three words boring as it sounds
raise your standards what does that mean
corny as it sounds raise your standards
well thank you for the breakthrough
thought Tony I'm glad I wasted my time
watching this little email with you but
think about it lasting change is
different than a goal you don't always
get your goals but you always get your
standards maybe it'll help you is to
think about it this way I try to explain
standards to people with a different set
of words think of it as everybody in
life gets their must they don't get
their shoulds right think about it most
be above a list of shoulds no they don't
you have a list of the shoulds things
you should do you should follow through
on I I should lose some weight I should
workout more I should make more calls I
should respond more rapidly to my email
whatever you know I should get into the
office earlier I should be you know more
confident whatever your should list is
people love to have their should list
make the net but it's kind of like New
Year's resolutions if it does it's
really exciting but if it doesn't which
is most the time it's a little
disappointing but you kind of know it's
not going to happen but when you decide
something as a must for you an absolute
must when you cut up any possible you
say I'm going to find the way I'm going
to make the way human beings when they
resolve things and they have make a real
resolution inside themselves which is
they raise the
and they make it a must they find the
way think about in your own life happens
you had some area of your life where you
raise your standard and your life has
never been the same maybe at one time
your life you use smoke cigarettes or
you did something and you did it for
years and you kept trying to change it
trying to change it and kept telling
yourself I should and then one day
something happened something just
clicked you over something took you over
that kind of tipping point and inside
yourself you said no more there was a
very very different experience wasn't it
something inside you shifted and what
was a should became a must and you've
never gone back is there an area like
that in your life you can think of again
do you ever smoke cigarettes did you
ever eat a certain way drink a certain
form of alcohol then finally saying no
more you just don't go back and notice
this it doesn't really take any
willpower anymore because somewhere when
we make this click we make something a
must we attach ourselves to it it
becomes part of our identity one thing
I've learned in the last gosh 33 years
are working people from now over 100
countries 4 million people is human
beings absolutely follow through on who
they believe they are if you say it said
to me well I'm really going to work hard
to stop smoking but you know I've been a
smoker my whole life and I'm you know I
am a smoker I know your days are
numbered you going to be back smoking
cigarettes again because we all act
consistent with who we believe we are
I tell people the strongest force in the
whole human personality is this need to
stay consistent with how we define
ourselves
if you define yourself as somebody who
is really conservative you're not going
to be crazy and act nuts unless you're
really drunk or something and then you
can say it's the alcohol when it really
does you finally getting permission to
be yourself the alcohol is your excuse
if you're a really crazy person you act
crazy outrageous playful you don't act
conservative because that's not who you
are
fern often people say well I can't do
that I'm not that kind of person and I
always say to people really when did you
define yourself I mean really how many
years ago did you come up with what you
could and couldn't do in your life how
many years ago most people if they
really look at how to living their life
today
it's
on a set of standards a set of beliefs
that they made choices about 10 20 30 or
more years ago I mean very often we made
decisions in our youth or very young
about what to believe about what we were
capable of about who we are as a person
and that becomes the glass ceiling if
you will that controls us there's a
corny metaphor but it's true I remember
one time I was with my family at the
circus and there's a person there and
they had this big giant elephant and you
look at this elephant and they take this
little rope put around the elephant's
neck and they drive the stake into the
ground and I mean you look at this you
know that elephant could rip down the
entire tent with almost no effort and
yet the elephant doesn't struggle
doesn't try why because the elephant's
conditioned and they take that elephant
conditioned the elephant when it's a
baby elephant that's how they train them
when it's a little baby elephant and it
doesn't have the power yet they put a
big rope around it and they drive this
huge stake in the ground and the
elephant fights and fights and fights
and one day finally that elephant
decides I'm not capable Alling this out
and once that becomes the definition of
an identity of anyone an elephant in
this case they don't even try anymore
it's just who I am that's how it is
that's just the way it is in my life I'd
like to ask you to take a look at any
place you've got a limitation ask
yourself when did I decide to accept
that limitation and you may not even see
it as a limitation you might see that
just that's who I am
but so often in our lives we've adapted
to be a certain way so that we don't
fail or so that people will like us or
respect us but it's not necessarily who
we are joy comes when you're spontaneous
it's really hard to be truly happy when
you're not being yourself and most of us
have no clue who we are and so a big
part of my work if you've ever been to
an event you know is to get people or do
things spontaneously without thinking
because that's when the real you shows
up that's when the energy comes alive
and when you do that when you start to
connect your true nature suddenly
there's energy available for you to set
a higher standard for what you want in
your life that's what this is really all
about and when I talk about standards
when I talk about you know shoulds
versus must think about your own life I
know there have been areas in your life
where some point in time you just
shifted and you
is the standard in your life change
because whatever people have their
identity attached to they live we live
who we believe we are that's just how it
works
it's just kind of like I give an example
look at your physical body your physical
body today
is an absolute reflection of only one
thing not your goals not your desires
but your standards the identity you have
for yourself if your standard is you're
an athlete then there's a certain amount
of strength a muscle tone and energy
that's available in your body on a
regular basis because that's who you are
and so you do whatever is necessary to
maintain that identity again the
strongest force and the human
personalities this need to stay
consistent with how we define ourselves
because if you don't know who you are
you would not act once you lock in on
that identity your brain finds a way to
keep you there if you say you know and
I'm overweight I've always been
overweight I'm big-boned and that's the
story you got then you're going to
always find a way to get back there
that's you're settling point that's your
identity that's where things lock in if
you see somebody who's in really great
shape you ask him do you work out you
know the answer yes how often and
they'll tell you three times four times
five times a week whatever in a seminar
last people who here works out at least
five days a week and I'm stand-up and
you look around that room and you know
they work out five times a week as you
can see their body you don't just get a
result without some kind of action
without some form of ritual ritual
meaning actions you do consistently now
do you think you knows people that are
out there working out five days a week
do they have more time than you do or I
have for anybody else of course not is
that a wipe less busy of course not it's
just a must for them they must work out
that way and they've made that turn
their life changed so I'm not saying you
have to work out five days a week I'm
just saying whatever you really want
once don't get met consistently
standards do whatever you identify this
is Who I am and so it's not so much
about changing your identity as there's
expanding it you know deciding that you
know instead of your goals to lose 10
pounds which is not compelling what if
your vision
was to get back to my fighting weight
you know just this year this month this
next 90 days I'm gonna transform my body
I'm gonna take on a new challenge I'm
gonna find some technique or strategy
there's a million of them that can
reframe myself where I want to feel
younger stronger more vibrant than ever
before here's my reasons because I want
the energy to really make my life work
because it's tough out there and I want
to be stronger than I've ever been
before
I'd only go in front of mirror if I'm
naked not you know want to laughs I want
look there and take a good look and go
yeah I'm proud of whatever I see there
whatever it takes something's going to
make you laugh smile something that's
going to tease yourself but something's
going to move you to another level if
you identify yourself in a new way and
you own that every day and that becomes
the standout you live you'll find the
way to make that standard real money is
the same way
think about it doesn't matter what's
happening quote-unquote in the
marketplace people that make money find
a way to make money no matter what don't
they I mean most people's standard is to
pay their bills so that's what most
people find a way to do even when
economic times get tough most people if
that's their absolute standard they find
a way some people's standard is pay
their bills most of the time and so most
of the time they do some people standard
is not just to pay their bills but to
take care of their family and maybe even
some of their friends and they find a
way in fact you know some people may be
in a family where they don't have enough
money you barely have money pay their
bills they work through guts out and
then somebody their mother their father
or somebody else their sister gets ill
and there's not enough money to take
care of it nobody else has money and
family they don't either but they find a
way to get that money to take care of
their mother or father don't they and
pay their bills they never could do it
before why the situation made them raise
their own standard and not everybody
does that somebody else in the family
might have money and still don't take
care of their mother it all comes down
to the inner game my friends changing
your life is a change in the inner game
the outside world you can't control but
you have absolute control of this one if
you learn that dynamics of what shapes
you and identity is one of those simple
clear fundamental basics that if you
start to shift it everything else will
shift in your life as well some people
by the way have to have more than enough
to do what they want when they want
where they want with whomever they want
contribute the way they want if that's
their must they find a way I know that
sounds overly simplistic but it's true
now somebody once said you can take all
the money in the world out of the hands
of everybody out of all the wealthy
people in the world who are really
successful given to other people it
wouldn't take too long those people have
it back in their hands it's not because
they're manipular it's because they have
a standard some are manipulative me
wrong but they got a standard of what
they're going to find a way to make
happen I'm just simply saying to you
take those three magic words and live
them raise your standard Michael Gerber
the guy that wrote the e-myth you know
talks about why so many businesses young
businesses fail and one of these things
he says is most people are not really
entrepreneurs but they think that's what
they should be they think that's the
sexy thing that's the most attractive
thing that's the best answer and what I
say to you is you've got to separate the
vehicle from the outcome what is it
that's going to truly fulfill you what
is it that's going to give you that
extraordinary life what's going to make
things magnificent on your terms not
somebody else's terms not your father
your mother your background what is that
really separate the vehicle there's many
ways to get to that vehicle but I'm
saying sometimes you got to re-evaluate
what's going to really make you fulfill
what is your gift are you an artist are
you the talent can produce something no
one else produces as a skill or a
product or a service or some impact are
you incredibly good at management you
really know how to manage or lead people
are you an extraordinary entrepreneur
that has can take that gigantic gut load
of risk and can create the vision and
attract the talent that you need in the
managers and leaders you may have all
three abilities but which one really
fulfills you the most is going to be the
critical question because we tend to
want to do them all especially the room
like this because you're all
overachievers right me too and you say I
can do all these yes you can but what
will it do to your quality of life see
again the secrets going to be this what
is an extraordinary life on your terms
today things getting things is not going
to make you happy
that's good news in a tough economy it's
a good reminder you know doesn't matter
you get doesn't matter whether it be
money or opportunity all those things
might excite you for the moment you know
even a relationship as magnificent it
may be might be exciting for a while but
if you don't keep growing that
relationship isn't going to stay
exciting so the secret to real happiness
is progress progress equals happiness
and if we can make progress on a regular
basis we feel alive and that's why at
the beginning of the year we get this
thing like okay I can have this fresh
start I could really do what my soul
desires I could expand I could grow I
can improve I could change or maybe
better than change I could progress see
think about that progress as an
aliveness - it doesn't it you don't have
to work at changing people say all the
time that allow I'm working on changing
don't worry about it
the work on changing changes automatic
your body's going to change whether you
want it or not as the years go by you no
matter how hard you work there's going
to be some changes going on there the
economy is going to change no matter
what you want it to do the weather is
going to change relationships are going
to change everything in life is always
changing we have to work on change
change is automatic but progress is not
so if you want to make real progress
then you really got to look at your life
in a different way you got to say I got
to take control of this process and not
just hope that's going to work out like
people do who make a resolution to treat
people at the end of the relationship
like it's the beginning and it won't be
an end and that's not just your intimate
relationship what if your customers what
if you fell in love with your customers
with your clients more than your product
more than your company if your entire
life was about meeting their needs if
you would do what for your customers
clients you would do what if you loved
your customers and clients you'd do
anything
guess what they're going to love you but
most people love their customers and
clients as long as they buy from them do
what they want respond to them and then
they don't they go that's the end you
want clients for life not just customers
fall in love of them it's a different
focus isn't it it's a different meaning
and that creates a different life
because you make decisions differently
from that place what does it take to
create world-class marketing what is the
unique selling proposition what is what
we call value-added marketing VI M today
most people are sick and
hired in advertising because where is it
everywhere in fact I got a question for
you how many of you in this room do not
even see banner ads anymore literally
it's there but you don't perceive it
like there's like your brain literally
washes it out raise your hand if that's
true keep your hands nice and high and
look around the room right now and
you'll see 98% of the people wash it out
so don't buy them unless you're going to
create something really unique it's a
total waste of your money in your time
of the world rent today today what
creates marketing is when you don't just
market but you add value to people you
do something you teach them you give
them an insight you give something
valuable that cost them nothing and then
they look to you as an expert they look
to you as a person adds value they want
they want you to supply them more
information more experience more
products more services if you let me
this whole business about meeting your
needs you can run a successful business
but it'll be a job because you'll never
be able to sell it because it was just
meeting your needs it's not a system it
demands your attention or your
connection it's giving what you want but
ultimately it's not going to give
somebody else what they want so you
can't sell it if you can't sell your
business if you don't have an exit
strategy you have a job I don't care how
successful the businesses you that
doesn't mean you have to sell the
business but one of the most important
decisions you make in business is
ultimately if I was going to sell this
my chose two I have to know who I sell
this to so that I have long term value
not just an income along the way I have
this critical mass here I get a multiple
of my business and most people don't
have a clear exit strategy they think
I'll come up with that some day you're
going to start with that end in mind
that's got to be part of your focus if
you're going to be successful in your
business I can remember gentlemen is
built CAA in Hollywood is largest most
successful agency right Michael Ovitz
remember that name he put together Nike
and coca-cola and these billion-dollar
deals and eventually Mike Ovitz went to
go sell that business he never thought
through an exit strategy they got almost
nothing for it because the laws
prevented him from selling it to a
studio he had a cell to some his
employees for pennies on it's real value
I might found a way to make money later
on another place off of Disney
but the bottom line is the guy didn't
have an exit strategy there was
brilliant made lots of money in the end
didn't get the value whenever people
fail to achieve their goals 99.9% of
time you ask him why they'll tell you
it's because of a lack of resources
that's what all these things are I
didn't have the support right I didn't
have the money we didn't have the time
we didn't have this we know that there's
a resource that people believe is
missing and that resource belief
structure then keeps people from ever
being able to really lead because what
leaders do is they find a way to
maximize whatever resources they have
has little as they may be and they don't
believe in limited resources I'll give
an example take a business example to
start with in 1974 I gained team Psalm
Walt and had built his little company up
he came with an idea started with
$20,000 and I think 1962 if I remember
right but by 1974 within 12 years he had
78 stores and you know I did it in the
middle of the night he drive across
border and he'd go and study other
people's stores he'd buy everything the
cheapest he could in the middle of the
night he'd go to the people's stores
whatever was working he figured out
success leaves Clues he came back and
did in his store whatever was working in
any store in any competitor anywhere he
could do it he did it so he forgot to
maximize the little resources he had his
twenty thousand build 78 stores and if
you read any of the people following him
the company gone public in that year
they were all saying this is it he's
maximized his resources I mean only have
so much money there's only so many
cities that are going to appeal to this
discounting mentality right this is it
this is all he can do and the word on
Wall Street was self now what's
interesting is at that time you look at
Sears and Kmart and they were gargantuan
companies weren't that 20 30 40 50 two
times a hundred times his size or more
probably and at that time they were the
leaders and they knew what's going to
happen but two things change yes or no
did he suddenly get mass amounts of
capital no here's what they didn't
understand Sam Walton now or the Walton
organization Walmart is the most
successful retailing operation on earth
and when you talk about Bill Gates being
the richest man in the world that's only
true because Sam's fortune is divided up
a bunch of different family members you
put them together they dwarf Bill Gates
Sam Walton did this how did he do it
what people underestimated is that this
guy could go to 4,400 stores do 250
billion
where's Kmart today and they've been
shrinking all the mature inking and he's
the dominant force on earth here's the
thing he understood resources are
interesting but the ultimate resources
are the feelings of emotion that make
you resourceful think of it this way
resourcefulness is the ultimate resource
what do I mean what are the emotions
that make all this possible what's the
fuel that takes an idea from being in
your head well you intellectually know
what to do how many got an idea for
example was a great idea you're excited
about it and then you didn't do anything
one day there you saw it on the Shelf
you saw it somewhere someone stole your
idea how many had this happen say ah
you'll end up seeing you and that person
was not that they have more resources
they were more resourceful success and
failure are not giant events they don't
just show up you don't just suddenly
become successful or suddenly have this
cataclysmic event that makes you fail
they look that way but failure comes
from all the little things its failure
to make the call
its failure to check the books its
failure to say I'm sorry its failure to
push yourself to do things physically
that you don't want to do and all those
little failures day after day come
together until one day some cataclysmic
event happens you blame Matt that event
happened because you missed all the
little stuff do you agree with me and
success by the way is not some overnight
event it's all these little things
success is having a vision success is
making it compelling success is really
seeing it feeling it every day was
strong enough for reasons success he is
feeling the sense that I'm here to grow
and I'm here to give something to the
world more than just myself all the
little stuff that's where success comes
from in business it comes from
delivering more than anybody could
imagine all those little things add up
people go wow that's who I want to do
business with it's true in any area of
your life leverage is critical you know
I get so much done because I don't just
get it done
I know the outcome I know the purpose
and I look for leverage leverage is
different than delegation
what's problem a delegation delegation
is you eivol what needs to be done so
you give it to someone else and you tell
them it needs to be done and they don't
do it you're pissed off leverage says I
can move the biggest Boulder in the
world with a little bit of effort if I
get something I can do it with but I'm
still part of it
so leverage is if I'm going to leverage
something here with Tom I'm going to
make sure Tom understands the what the
outcome I wanna make sure Tom
understands the the purpose the why and
the action but I might say to tell them
if you get this done without this action
or better action go for a baby and I
want to talk to you on this date and we
got a promise and we're going to check
in before it's needed so there's no
surprises if you have a problem come
back to me because we're partners on
this now I call leverage and you know
what I do when I have no time there is
time I just got to leverage it now
saying you say I have no leverage you
too you know Shane over here right I
know stuff he wants to do can't leverage
it but Shane's answer was hire somebody
then he thinks about what it's going to
take and goes 125,000 dollars can't do
that now he's getting caught up in one
way to get the outcome leverage he goes
who's listening goes what if I got
somebody who 20% of this stuff I got I
could spend 20 grand to get that much
freedom I could pay four times ten hmm
and if I'm really productive my
productivity should enhance the world
not only my clients and customers but it
should provide jobs for other people and
if there's anything you hate to do it's
because you're either ineffective at it
or you don't think it's very important
but it is urgent so you hire somebody
for those things and ideally somebody
who loves that job you're never going to
grow when your time is eaten up for
activities that aren't that important
activity without high levels of purpose
is the drain of your fortune do it now
if you can't get it all now to a part of
it now leverage is power leverages
ultimate power here's what I've created
from my life and anyone who knows
succeeded I'm a 17 year old kid from
Azusa California with no real education
other than self education with no
background with parents that did their
best all of them
with no money but I did one thing I love
people and I had an enormous demand I
made upon myself and I sculpted my mind
and my emotions to get me to do whatever
it would take to achieve and to
contribute but to do that I did it by
using my body and changing my focus I
did it by putting myself in a peak
physiology and using what I call
incantations can you train yourself to
believe something yes or no absolutely
how many have ever made the fatal
mistake of going to Disneyland or Disney
World and while you're there made the
fatal mistake of going to a ride called
it's a small world after all what
happens for about a week after you're
out of that damn place you're still
singing this thing in your hand in 24
languages right let me tell you
something how many of you have things
when you want to go Chiva man this part
of your voice goes on it's not going to
happen or forget it I'm gonna go to
voice that sometimes interrupts that
good pattern say I what you want to do
is train a new one
so starting when I was 17 I started
doing incantations not affirmations
affirmation you go unhappy unhappy
amantha I'm happy I'm happy
what's the problem you haven't changed
your what your what physiology if you
don't change your physiology you won't
get anything so an incantation only you
speak it but you embody what you're
saying with all the intensity you can
and you do it with enough repetitions
that it sticks in your head like it's a
small world now the conversation your
head is always the same and it gives you
what you want so use your body and your
voice so 17 years ago I started doing
things I was working for Jim Rohn this
speaker when I was 17 years old I had
long hair minestrone soup acne on my
face I was trying to call on Bear
Stearns type of people and convince them
why they should go to this man seminar
be more successful I was driving a 1968
Volkswagen I'd earned it $40 a week as a
janitor the only way I did it was park
far from the building and then go in and
I love people I believe what I put
myself in state and I was able to
influence people that were far more
successful I was at the time I will do
something that I still do backstage and
I've done for 23 years because I don't
hope I'm going to be
could stay I demand it so I do an
incantation using my whole body I now
command my subconscious mind to direct
me in helping as many people as possible
life today to better their lives they
gave me the strength the emotion the
persuasion the humor the brotherly
whatever it takes
you surely feel and get these people to
change their lives now I would do that
literally driving in my Volkswagen to a
meeting in LA on the freeway for 40
minutes people love him I'm screaming to
top my lungs they're going I know he's a
serial killer I know he is but by the
time I entered that room when two people
meet if there's rapport the person who's
most certain will always influence the
other person and I was totally certain
and they were trying to get revved up to
certainty do you agree with this yes or
no I do another one because I was poor I
changed my mindset I kept doing things
but I never got beyond it
I'd say gods wealth is circulating in my
life as well flows to me an avalanche is
of abundance all my needs desires and
goals are met instantaneously by
infinite intelligence I'm one with God
and God is everything and I would
imagine the abundance of my life and I
would feel so grateful and a year later
I went for making $38,000 zero to make a
million dollars a year in one year thank
you so much for watching I made this
video because Subash Lin boo and my
cameraman Jason asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Tony
Robbins top 10 rules was the most
impactful on you leave it in the
comments and I'll join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon
you
there's a man named Ken Blanchard who
wrote those books called the one minute
manager books and he said to me very
early in my life he said Tony he said a
business will always consume whatever is
available and he said I see you're
coming out with your first book I was 24
it was unlimited power and he goes
you're come out of this book I think it
to be a big success do not put that
money in your business take that money
and put it into a separate investment
account that nobody else touches he said
I'm telling you the business get all the
benefit of all the media of all the
things that come to it but the actual
dollars of that should stay out so the
same thing when I had an infomercial he
said you know take that money put it
aside well it was only the best advice I
ever got in my entire life because I put
it aside and there were times in that
money with needed but I was like putting
it in a chapel I was like putting it
where it was sacred money and was not
going to be touched if someone came
along and said you have no money for
your business but guess what mama just
raised the taxes 20% more for your
business you scream you yell you be
upset and you bad so why not put your
family first why not have a portion of
what you own and what you earn I should
say for yours to keep it doesn't go to
Kate Spade it doesn't go to Wall Street
it goes to your family and the way you
do that is you tax yourself it's a
wealth back you go that's my freedom
fund and that comes off the top and the
secret is automated so you don't see it
that's really the most important very
often you're getting what you're asking
for you're just not aware of how general
you're asking clarity is power the more
clear you are about exactly what it is
you want the more your brain knows how
to get there
your brain is a servomechanism it's like
a bomb those bombs those missiles they
have a servomechanism so if the target
moves it knows what the target is it
follows it your brain when you condition
it knows exactly what to go for it will
find a way to get there you ever buy a
certain outfit or a certain car and
suddenly see that car outfit everywhere
how many had that experience say I how
come that car outfits everywhere it
always was everywhere but now you notice
it and reason because there's a part of
your brain called the reticular
activating system the RAS that part of
your brain determines what you notice
and what you don't notice your brain
spends most of its time trying to make
sure you don't notice because you'll go
crazy if you notice everything but when
you decide what's most important to you
your brain goes after it
everyone I know successful have been
is what I call an RPM plan and rpm is
built on the metaphor that the way to
get from where you are to where do you
want to go to the fastest is you got to
build power like in a car rpms and the R
stands for they know the result they're
after they know what they want precisely
if you don't know exactly what you want
or you let yourself get beyond that into
something general you're not going to
achieve it clarity is power you got to
know the specific result you after what
do you want you can't answer that
question right now in your personal life
in your body in your relationships and
your finances and your spirituality then
you're not going to be as fulfilled as
you want to be here's my assignment for
if you want one if you want to go from
conversation to some action your simple
thing to do what's an area life right
now that you really want to prove what's
an area that's important to improve to
your body's great how about your career
career is great about your relationship
intimate one especially or your kids or
your relationship with your Creator
spiritual side of your life or is it
your finances figure an area that really
matters decide on that area number one
write down what your life is like in
that area right now specifically as
possible so you might say well I'm 13.5
pounds overweight you know whatever the
weight is whatever the situation is or
my body fats like this or wake up
exhausted in the morning and you write
the truth of where you are right now
so you're real clear or I'm not in a
relationship I say I want a relationship
but I I'm not in one I don't seem to
find them all the good ones seem to be
gone is my belief you know and I really
do want one but I don't have it whatever
your definition I'm in a relationship
and god I wish I wasn't in a
relationship I'm planning my escape
wherever you are or I have a wonderful
relationship we'd love each other but
there just isn't enough passion just
right the truth of where you are the
area you want to change what right how
it is and then the second step is that's
where you got to be really honest with
yourself what are the rituals that have
put me that because whatever results
you're getting even if you don't like
the results there are some rituals that
are keeping you in that place there are
some rituals of what you eat or don't
eat how you move or don't move how you
sleep or don't sleep there's some
rituals and the lack of variety or spice
or energy or focus in an area there's
something you're doing and it's usually
not one thing it's a bunch of little
things
they kind of do consistently whatever
you think about getting in a
relationship whenever you think about
working out whenever you think about
money and get yourself in a state of
overwhelm you start thinking about
things you can't control just write down
all the rituals you have and then here's
the third step what do you want what's
your vision and be really specific I
want to be my fighting way I want to be
the strongest I've ever felt I want to
be I'm going to turn my whatever it is
be specific and then last step number
four what are the rituals that will get
you there what would you need to
differently each morning if you're going
to be that kind of energy that kind of
strength how would you have to often
would you work out what days would you
work out what time ritual is something
you do consistently usually at a
specific time so becomes automatic let
me tell you something willpower doesn't
last
but rituals can last a lifetime I bet
you have some rituals in your life right
now you've been doing for years even
though some of them don't serve you
I'm just saying wake yourself up make if
you want a new year and a new life you
don't need to start in January first
start today start with this little video
and just begin to see what happens and
see how easy it is to just do a few
little rituals don't do them all just do
two or three new things and you know
what happens you'll get momentum because
once you discipline yourself in one area
life you feel yourself doing in other
areas as well I always say something
that my original teacher taught me I
always remind people there's always two
pains in life there's the pain of
discipline or as the pain of regret and
discipline weighs ounces as my friend
Jim Rohn taught me regret weighs tons
you don't have regret so right now what
do you want to change what's it really
like one of the rituals that got you
there that will take a little homework
if you're not sure ask the people around
you they'll tell you what your rituals
are what do I really want in depth where
the rituals will get me there and then
get yourself to start a few those
actions and lock them in place